in case you have fallen asleep by then
so phones lecture on repairing damaged
databases remind me of a joke Dave
McQueen told me many years ago so
there's this robot that has been built
as a prototype to perform household
tasks and it can actually understand
natural language so you can speak to it
in ordinary English and it has this
repair mechanism built into it so that
it automatically corrects mistakes in
things that it hears so they feel tested
by sending it to a neighborhood and it's
supposed to go from door to door and
offer to do household tasks so it goes
to a house and it says is there anything
you want me to do and the guy says yeah
go paint the porch out back so the robot
goes with a can of white paint it comes
back after an hour and says I have
finished by the way it was a BMW these
are the amongst the dangers of automatic
repair mechanisms so last time or
yesterday it seems like years ago but it
was just yesterday I talked about by
simulation as a way of talking about
behavioural equivalence of systems or
states within a system and I argued that
it was not such a good thing in fact to
rely on something as brutally abrupt as
a yes/no concept like an equivalence
relation when you have quantitative data
describing your system so today I'm
going to talk about metrics which give
you a more graceful and more
quantitative way of relating system
behaviors okay so I will after a brief
introduction I will talk about metrics
for by simulation and then give a kind
of logical view this time based on a
real-valued modal logic and finally I
will conclude with concluding remarks so
process equivalence is fundamental as we
have seen before with Markov chains in
fact the concept very concept very much
like by simulation was already there in
queueing theory as far back as the early
60s it was called lump ability and the
name is very evocative it means you can
lump those things together if you
discover that they satisfy this
particular behavioral equivalence
relation well labeled Markov processes
as I described yesterday we have this
concept called by simulation and indeed
later on we extended this to Markov
decision processes where you have a
notion of reward you also have a by
simulation concept independently and a
few years later this was rediscovered by
people in the machine learning community
one can also look at so called labeled
concurrent markov chains where we
combine probability and non determinism
so you have a notion called week by
simulation and you you really have to
start struggling with the difference
between probability and non determinism
and their interaction but for all these
things you have equivalence relations
that capture some kind of behavioral
property of interest but in the context
of probability this kind of exact
equivalence relation is not very
reasonable a small change in the
probability distribution leads to
suddenly saying Oh suddenly things that
had been by similar are no longer by
similar and yet they might be very close
in their behavior and we would like to
capture this in some quantitative way so
the idea is that one should have a
pseudo metric for probabilistic
processes so let me just remind you what
a pseudo metric is so it's just like a
metric it's a binary function on some
space that gives you positive real
numbers associate that you should think
of as being like distances and
importantly if you have the distance
from a point to itself is zero but you
can have distinct points at zero
distance that's why it's a pseudo metric
rather than a regular metric now
there are other variations that have
also been considered like heavy metrics
were which are not even symmetric
something that has been brought home to
me as I cycle to work and back up and
down the hill but in general in geometry
one likes to consider symmetry as a
defining property of zero metrics and
one has the standard triangle inequality
now the point is that this is a very
nice analogue quantitative analogue of
the notion of equivalence relation you
can think of this thing as saying
everything is close to itself you can
think of this thing as saying if
something is close to something else
than the reverse also holds and this one
is like a transitivity thing if s is
close to T and T is close to you then s
will be close to you okay so in some
quantitative sense this is very much
analogous to the notion of an
equivalence relation so it seems to be
the natural replacement for that if you
insist
that x and y can be at zero distance if
and only if they are the same then we
get the standard notion of metric and if
you have such a pseudo metric which
doesn't impose that then you
automatically get an equivalence
relation by deeming two points to be
equivalent if they are at zero distance
you can then of course quotient by that
equivalence relation to get a bonafide
metric on the appropriate equivalence
classes and this is well defined by the
triangle inequality okay so that's a
brief summary of metrics and pseudo
metrics these are going to be the things
that I will be using to compare the
behaviors of systems so let's look back
at by simulation so we had an
equivalence relation and we said that do
States s and T were by similar if s
could jump by an a transition and
produce some kind of probability
distribution say P then T could also
jump to some other probability
distribution and P and Q should be
somehow are are related I will say
exactly what this means and vice versa
so this
Taoiseach means basically that p and q
agree on unions of our equivalence
classes so on are closed measurable sets
so this is the definition from yesterday
and now again this is an equivalence
relation we'll say s and T are by
similar if I can find a by simulation
relation relating them so basically if
you're trying to prove two systems are
by similar you look around for an
appropriate R that relates the two that
you're interested in and you can prove
the standard things there is a maximum
by simulation relation which is by
similarity itself now the basic
properties that you want to mimic in the
quantitative case one is that you have
this kind of Co induction principle
namely that if you can find a by
simulation R that relates s and T that
gives you a technique for showing things
are by similar this is basically the
greatest fixed point property of by
simulation how do you tell if two states
are not by similar while you use the
logical characterization and you look
for formulas on which they disagree this
will tell you that things can't be by
similar if you found a formula on which
they disagree the nice thing about this
particular modal logic is that you can
interpret these modal formulas as
experiments that you can do to try and
make manifest the difference in the
behavior okay so if you say if you see
some nested sequences of diamonds you
say do an A and then a b and then SE and
then you will see that something doesn't
match up so it's actually giving you a
thing to look for in fact there is a
famous case study which was done by the
upall group at Aalborg
who implemented a real-time model
checking system which included things
that could check for timed problem timed
by simulation and there was this case
study which they did with in conjunction
with bang and olufsen where they had a
system that was misbehaving for about
two years the engineers who designed the
system couldn't debug it they knew
something was wrong but they couldn't
exactly pin it down and then the old
ball group spent about three or four
months
developing abstract model of the system
and then running it to their mortal
checker and asking it if these two
things were by similar the specification
and the description of what had been
built and it said no and it produced the
witnessing formula that showed that they
weren't and that was in fact a trace of
the behavior where the anomaly showed up
so this happened some time back but we
still repeat it as one of our favorite
case studies of where the theory and the
practice got together so being able to
distinguish States through such a simple
logic is actually a very nice thing so
back in 1990 Joe and Scott smolka
suggested that one should move from an
equality between processes to such a
pseudo metric okay so this gives a
quantitative measure of the distinction
between processes they actually proposed
metric which was quite an interesting
one it had unfortunately one bad feature
which was there were things that were at
zero distance that weren't by similar so
it was in fact quite difficult to come
up with a metric that had the feature
that you wanted which was yes zero
distance should correspond to I can't
see a difference at all it should
correspond to the equivalence relation
of by similarity and that's what we
finally did almost a decade after that
so the basic results that one is able to
establish in this case is an analogous
Co induction principle an ability to
kind of a logic which is this time a
real-valued modal logic which allows you
to distinguish States and proof that the
equational and the logical views
actually coincide so this particular
proof was done by Franklin Bruegel and
James world one can also imagine
applying this not just to label
transition systems but one can imagine a
syntax a primitive programming language
if you will for describing these systems
and you can show that process
combinators take nearby processors to
nearby processes the basic property here
is non expansiveness if things are at
certain distances then when you combine
them there will still be close
and this is the analog of being
compositional so these kinds of results
we actually did for a variety of closely
related systems Markov chains MDPs and
so on okay so what do we want we want
first of all that if the pseudo metric
says that two systems or two states are
at zero distance we want them to be
properly by similar we would like this
distance to stay stable under temporal
evolution so nearby states shouldn't
diverge soon they should stay closed for
a for a long time otherwise you have no
right to call them similar if they
quickly manifest differences ideally the
metrics should be computable and I will
say a bit about all these things
presently so let's go back to the
definition of by simulation here it is
written out again in the same way as
before and we would like to convert this
now do a quantitative definition so
here's something we can try let's
imagine that we have a metric on the
state space so I'll call it M and let's
suppose that these two states are close
what should that mean then it should
mean that whenever s can do a transition
to P and let's forget about labels for
for now so let's assume there's only one
label so s does a transition it scatters
out to some probability distribution P
then T should also be able to scatter
out to some probability distribution Q
and those should be close as well and
vice-versa so this looks like very close
analogy with what we had with the
definition of by simulation except that
this metric was defined between the
points of the transition system and here
I'm using it between the distributions
defined on top of that same metric space
so this is a type mismatch it's not the
same thing it's not the same space of
course so what we need is some way to
lift distances from States to distances
on distributions over the states and
this is the main
technical part so I'm going to go to a
longer detour through the so called
kantorovich metric so this metric as I
said before has many names
it was often called the Hutchinson
metric the earth mover distance the
Wasserstein metric the kantorovich
metric and so on I think it's fair to
attributed to kantorovich so Villani
who's written a thousand-page book about
transport problems has a long at the end
of one of his chapters has a long
discussion on why it should be called a
kantorovich metric so this is a metric
on the probability measures themselves
defined on a metric space I said before
that probability theory works well when
you have a metric space so let me
introduce script m to be the lattice of
one bounded pseudo metrics right now
it's just a set I will give it lattice
structure presently and now the distance
that one natural way of measuring the
distance between two distributions is to
say well how differently do they compute
integrals so you look at non expansive
functions so you you say you integrate
one of them with respect to one of the
measures and then with respect to the
other measure and you see how different
the answers you get are and then you
look at that sort of maximized or souped
overall F in that class so this is one
very nice metric that one can use and it
turns out that this metric actually
arises in a linear programming problem
called transshipment so it's actually a
classic transportation problem which
used this particular metric and that's
how kantorovich came up with it so it's
actually interesting to note that
kantorovich published his paper in 1942
which was of course in the middle of
World War two and shortly after the
invasion of the Soviet Union by Germany
and there was a big transportation
problem that the Soviets had to do which
deal with which was to move all their
factories and industrial production east
so I'd like to think that this was
greatly facilitated by counter witch's
techniques but I don't know if that's
actually true or whether Stalin actually
listened to kantorovich but it's a nice
it's nice to imagine that this is one of
the things that contributed to the
defeat of Nazi Germany is it clear that
this is a finite number distance could
be infinite yes not on a compact set if
the underlying space is compact note
will be a finite number but in general
it could be so uh so I should say in
general we allow metrics that take on
extended real number values if I am
permitted to say category on the last
day let me say the category of of metric
spaces with extended metrics is a much
nicer category than the usual one you
remind me of Linda Ronstadt who said
categories are out okay sirs coma
yeah is it obvious
well you need some kind of condition
because otherwise I allow you to have
absolutely wild functions I can pick
things that really focus on where
they're differ and then you don't have
any control over the behavior of the
thing I think that's right
exactly like this but yeah so Frank has
written a paper called the metric
probability monad in which I think well
it uses the kantorovich metric but I
have not explained this transfer
shipment thing so let me do that
by talking about it in a very discrete
setting
are you happy tama or i use you still
want some compelling argument
okay so let's look at finite states
finite state spaces all right so we've
got probability distributions on a
finite set and the set is the underlying
space is given a metric structure so I
can sensibly talk about the distance
from a point si to another point s J so
there are n points or whatever s1
through SN and now the role of those FS
is played just by these numbers a sub I
which are required to be between 0 & 1
let's say and this is conditioned as the
discrete analog of being Lipschitz so
non expansive and now that soup has
become a Max and what it says is try and
choose these a I subject to these
constraints to maximize this and that
will define a metric on the
distributions P and Q okay doesn't yet
it's just a discrete analogue of the
thing I wrote down before in terms of
integrals it doesn't yet look like it
has anything to do with transshipment so
the dual form which I learned from a
paper of James Worrell and fanboy go
looks like this so instead of maximizing
something you minimize this expression
where now the variables are these l IJ s
ignore the x i's and the Y J's for now
or in fact forever they are what are
called slack slack variables for certain
which I've put there for certain
convenience but these are really the
things to focus on now what the heck
does all this means so maybe I will
switch to the board explain what's going
on
so here is one intuitively compelling
way I think compared to probability
distributions on a metric space so let's
say oops should have the same number of
points yeah so let's say I have a copy
of the space and at each point I have
put some pile of stuff a pile of sand at
each point and then so that of course I
can think of as the shape of some
distribution over the set and I want to
move it to something shaped differently
so in order to do so I have to ship sand
around perhaps this place needs to have
more this has a lot of sand on it so I
can move some from here to there so you
see I transport some sand from here to
there so if this is I and that's J how
much I ship from point I to point J is
the L IJ appearing in that okay now of
course associated with a shipping a
certain amount of sand from one place to
the other is a cost and the metric is
measuring that cost so what the L IJ
defines is called a transport plan
and this thing is measuring the cost of
that plan so what we're asking you to do
is find the minimum cost transport plan
to transform one distribution to another
and this turns out to be actually dual
to the previous maximization problem
okay so this is a very manifestly a
shipment problem and this is this is a
transshipment so these are what are
called slack variables to take up
discrepancies if P and Q are sub
probability distributions you might want
to have these so called slack variables
to take up the difference but in general
these things will always end up being
zero at least and the examples I look at
okay so putting them there allows me to
actually deal with sub distributions
that don't even have the same total mass
yes you mean I could have made them in
equation or constraints yeah I could
have but this is a more a nicer way to
do it okay so what's nice about duality
is you know when you first teach duality
to students they might say or you
replace one problem with another one's a
maximization the other is a minimization
but the point is one form allows you to
prove upper bounds on things the other
one allows you to prove lower bounds and
with the two of them together you tend
to squeeze you're able to squeeze things
and prove equations this is what we had
to do a lot in this work through various
equations by exploiting both aspects of
the dual formulation so let me do some
examples again very very simple examples
because that's all I think I can handle
right now
so let's show that the distance from a
distribution to itself is indeed zero
okay so you match each state with itself
so the transport plan is don't move
anything all right well that's very it's
easy to figure out the cost of that plan
it
zero and and now you clearly cannot be
lowered any further because the this
version says minimize the cost we've
already got down to zero so so this must
be the minimum cost plan to ship a
distribution to itself by simply not
moving anything so this is a very quick
and immediate proof that this lifted
metric has distance zero not so easy to
prove in the other form okay supposing I
have two points and let's say the
distance is strictly less than 1 and now
let's look at the Dirac distribution
totally concentrated at the point s and
compare it with the distribution
concentrated at the point P sorry the
point T so that's lifted metric you see
I'm using the same letter M because I
want to this example will kind of
justify it I want to show that the
distance between the distributions is
also R and now what you can do is simply
say well everything was that s I want to
move it to T it's kind of obvious what
the transport plan is ship everything
from s to T and then there's nothing
else that needs to be shipped and the
cost will indeed turn out to be R
but now this is only giving you an upper
bound to get the lower bound you have to
look at the other form and now you can
choose a s to be 0 82 BR and all others
to match the constraints and then you
can get that that sum is r since we've
matched the lower bound you actually
know that you now have an equality and
this distance is R so why is this
important
it shows that the original space
isometrically embeds inside the space of
distributions ok so it kind of justifies
the sloppiness of writing m for both
kinds of things so it just lives there
in terms of its direct distributions so
the third one is supposing the
probability of s is R and T is 0 and now
I move it to s having R Prime and T also
0 for all other things other than s now
what I've done is I've lost some mass so
that now I'd like to claim that the
distance between the distribution is
just the absolute value of the distance
between R and R prime ok so again you
can just choose appropriate choices for
a from the primal and you can choose
transport plan for the dual this time
you need a non-trivial X because you see
I don't have full distributions and then
you can check that the constraints are
satisfied and indeed you get this
distance again because you've got it
from both of them you know that you've
achieved the the right distance okay so
this detour again I did it for really
simple examples but the summary is that
given a metric on States in a metric
space given us have to give it a metric
on the state so you have a metric space
you can lift this to give a metric on
the probability distribution on States
and indeed as Bartek pointed out you
actually get a nice monad on the
category of metric spaces but you
probably didn't want to hear that so now
we can do metric by simulation without
the type anomaly that I had
before so we basically say this is the
idea if I have two things that are close
in my behavioral metrics so less than
some distance epsilon then after making
transitions there should be close that
just the quantitative analog of what I
had before when I had strictly qualities
now I just say they should be close so
the required canonical metric is the
least such thing that satisfies this
condition so ie the one in which the
distances are the least possible so what
actually happens is that you can
actually prove such a metric exists by
the following argument
so let me just remind you of Torquay's
theorem which has proved to be a
unifying thread in two or three
different series so if you have a
complete lattice you have managed to
misspell and you have a monotone
function from the lattice to itself then
the set of fixed points of F with the
induced order is itself a complete
lattice in particular there is both a
least fixed point and a greatest fixed
point of course they may coincide but in
general you'll get a nice lattice of
fixed points okay so here is how we use
it here so recall that we had this
script M the family of one bounded
pseudo metrics on states with ordering
so I'm going to define this order which
is kind of the reverse of the distance
ordering so if M one assigns bigger
distances then M 2 then I will say m 1
is below M 2 this may sound a bit
peculiar but there's a fairly good
reason for it
it's completely routine to check that
this is a complete lattice and let's
look at what the top and bottom looked
like so this one says s and T bottom
says SN T a zero distance if s is equal
to T and otherwise it's the maximum
possible distance remember these are 1
bounded so the top one simply says
everything is at 0 distance since these
are pseudo metrics
I can say stuff like that
and this is written this way with this
ordering which you might think is
reversed from its natural order because
it more closely resembles the lattice of
relations because if you look at the
lattice of relations ordered by
inclusion then the bottom element would
indeed be the guy that doesn't relate
anything except everything to itself
let's say the lattice of equivalence
relations and the maximal element would
be the one that says everything is
related which is indeed if that was my
pseudo metric the induced equivalence
relation would indeed relate everything
so in fact this reversed ordering is
indeed the one that corresponds to how
we were thinking about relations before
so now I will define a functional on
this lattice which says F of M between s
and T is closed if after a transition
the distributions P and Q that you get
or are closed so F gives you kind of a
one-step unwinding of the transition
relation and because this is a
probabilistic transition system after a
transition instead of a state I have a
distribution but that's okay now because
my metric actually measures
distributions as well as points so you
can actually write down an explicit
expression for this rather than then
this more suggestive form so you can
show that F is monotone and metric by
simulation indeed is the greatest fixed
port can be defined then as the greatest
fixed point of this functional on the
lattice of zero metrics
you said you can show no you can I think
I quickly corrected sure to define if
not I'm doing it now so you can show F
is monotone and hence define metric by
stipulation to be the greatest fixed
point okay so I don't want to tell you
anything about these proofs except to
mention a key tool which also appeared
in mic miss ellipse talk on Tuesday
called the splitting lemma so this
pleating lemma is not exactly the one
Claire Jones came up with it says but
it's closely related and was proved by
my student Josie so it says if you have
two probability distributions on a set
of states and you split P into a pair p1
plus p2 so these will be in fact sub
probabilities then you can also split Q
into Q 1 and Q 2 such that the distance
from P to Q will be the sum of those two
things so you can actually this will
allow you to take two distributions and
split them up into simpler pieces and
piece together the metric distance from
the from the individual pieces that
you've constructed so this turns out to
be a very crucial tool and almost
everything that we prove and you use
this in the discrete case just by
ordinary LP Theory linear programming
but on continuous basis you need a more
powerful theorem called kantorovich
rubenstein duality so I will tell you
what that is now so it's just the analog
of this thing except we don't have
points but you have some kind of metric
spaces okay so let me define terms here
supposing I have two probability
measures on some measurable space what
we call a coupling is a measure on the
product space such that the marginals
are the two measures that you started
with okay so
you have to measures you think of them
like this so I have the product space X
cross X the distribution p1 is the
marginal along the x axis the
distribution p2 is the marginal along
the y axis and you build some kind of
joint measure on the product space such
that you match the marginals so when you
do that that thing that you get is
called a coupling okay so i'll write c
p1 p2 for the set of all couplings
between p1 and p2 and you can think of
this as just generalizing that idea it's
giving you a transport plan for shipping
stuff around from one place to the other
so that the distribution p1 is
transformed until it becomes p2 ok so p1
might have some shape p2 will have some
completely different shape and you have
to move things around until the shape p1
is transformed into the shape p2 pi is
telling you a particular plan for doing
that there are of course many different
plans any such plan will be one of those
couplings
so the theorem says if I have a metric
on the underlying space that's measuring
my cost and I integrate so if Q is one
of my couplings so that means it Q is a
transport plan for transforming P 1 into
P 2 then the cost of that plan is this
now I take the info over all possible
couplings this is equal to the soup
again for F non expansive of this
distance difference
okay so again this one is measuring how
differently if p1 and p2 evaluate
integrals and this one is measuring how
much it takes to transform one
distribution into another and the
kantorovich Rubinstein theorem says
basically these will be the same guess
their various assumptions that I'm well
for example that the thing has to be
compact but these have been over the
years weakened so that the conditions
have been weakened that is so the
theorem has been strengthened and sorry
so the standard product no no not the
product measure measure on the product
space so what is what plan does the
product measure correspond to takes all
the stuff in p1 supposedly to a big bag
of random and randomly redistributes of
52 so the way you end up is independent
of where you began
you mean if you do people if you do P
cross P
you're not sure who each person is but
so there were many variations on this
the original formulation is given by
Marsh was about transporting rocks so
what the difference between rocks and
sand is because you can't break up rocks
sand you can are sand is infinitely
divisible and you can redistribute it as
much as you like the launch version said
I have a bunch of rocks here with this
total mass at each place and I want to
move it to another bunch of rocks there
and that may or may not be possible i
sort of it turned out to be a much
harder problem and kantorovich said
let's smash these rocks and make them
into sand and then you can actually do
it efficiently you can efficiently come
up with a plan yes yeah so but the
differently in the Mons problem and the
kantorovich problem is precisely this
business about being divisible yeah so
I'd like to think of it as rocks versus
sand so sometimes called the launch
kantorovich problem and sometimes is
called the earthmovers problem but I've
never heard it been called the rock
movers problem
so this particular metric coming out of
kantorovich to reality is also very much
used in computer vision though the
people who started calling it the
earthmovers distance and they use it to
compare so they think of an image as
just a probability distribution of pixel
intensities and they use it as a
comparison between two images okay so
that was imitating the by simulation
point of view so let's look at a more
logical point of view so I want to
develop a real-valued modal logic
doesn't make a difference that was kind
of a semi formal definition the actual F
there's an actual functional you can
write down explicitly and that's the
thing whose greatest fixed point you
compute I just wrote it like that's what
so that I could say things that are
close stay close I call it epsilon and
epsilon prime but then you would have
asked what's the relationship between
epsilon and epsilon prime so the logical
point of view so we want a real valued
modal logic based on this analogy which
I learned from Dexter achozen so
normally you think of program logics
like this you have a set of states you
have formulas and you have a
satisfaction relation linking them and
in the probabilistic world instead of
states you have distributions the analog
of formulas are random variables and the
analog of satisfaction the link that
hooks these two together is the integral
so indeed this particular analogy can is
I like to call it the hinge of duality
so there's a stone type duality here
there's a very analogous duality between
which I alluded to I think on Wednesday
so anyway this is the kind of thing that
led us to think about a metric based on
how closely random variables agree
so this is an alternative to the
kantorovich metric point of view so lets
us define this kind of syntax so we have
so this is just notation for what I'd
like to call functional expressions if
you wish this syntax for functions I
have to give you a semantics for how to
interpret the syntax on a given Markov
process so there's a constant one max of
two functions I can compose F with H
I'll tell you in a minute what H is and
then there's this funny diamond a dot F
thing where a is one of the actions of
my transition system so H is any
Lipschitz functions from the reals to
the reals so I'm allowed to compose that
with my function from from the states to
the reals so that's this functional
composition Max is max one is one and
now this a so a dot F is a new function
and the way you describe it is you take
the transition kernel I talked about at
length yesterday and you integrate f
with respect to that so you're computing
the expectation value of F after an a
transition has happened right now it
turns out convenient to put in a
contractive factor gamma which might in
fact not be contractive because i would
be closed interval one here and indeed
where the gamma is one or not we'll make
a stark difference okay so that's the
how you interpret these functions
and now we can define a metric by saying
take the soup over all the functions
that we get from this from the syntactic
description so it's not exactly it's so
syntactic because of course I'm allowing
you to then compose with an arbitrary
Lipschitz function but I will actually
make it more finite every presently you
take the soup overall setup F's of the
difference between f of s and F of T so
you can see this was kind of inspired by
kantorovich kantorovich like distance it
turns out you can prove that the met
well first of all that this is indeed a
proper metric but there that metric
coincides with the fixed point
definition of metric by simulation I
gave before okay so this theorem is
actually nothing but the quantitative
analogue of the logical characterization
of by simulation results that I talked
about yesterday that theorem does not
depend on the choice of gamma that's
correct
however other things do depend on the
choice of camera so in fact is a good
well I will talk about gamma and and its
role a bit later a more finite area
syntax for these functions is as follows
so we allow this kind of negation by
allowing you to write 1 minus F in
addition to the diamond a dot F we
introduce this new thing called a cutoff
so what does cutoff does is it says we
will if F is if F of S is greater than Q
we will cut you down to Q otherwise we
will let you be and here again we insist
on Q being irrational so now you have a
finite or e syntax for this modal logic
and you can actually prove that you get
exactly the same metric if as it as the
syntax that I had before that allowed
arbitrary the Pitts functions to be
composed with your apps okay so this is
kind now the logical view of the same
distance okay the role of gamma so what
the heck does gamma do so what it does
is it discounts the value of future
steps so it's saying if you're if trying
to compare two processes that are
evolving dynamically then if their
difference appears after a long time you
will discount that and say yes they're
very similar after a long time they
might might start looking different but
since it took so long
we will discount that and not count it
as much as if they manifested
differences immediately this kind of
discounting distance or discounted value
functions and so on appears all over
machine learning all over
MDP theory and stuff like that but what
happens if gamma is one if you look at
the topology that you get gamma is
strictly less than 1 and gamma equal to
1 yield very different topologies and
perhaps
it's worth showing examples that
illustrate this
consider this sequence of systems
so and compare them
the system that just cycles on itself
so if gamma is strictly less than one
these things actually converge to that
one because the time when you see the
difference
gets postponed further and further so if
gamma is equal to one
these things are always the same
distance from that self looping thing
and they will never converge so it's not
just that they yield different metrics
they actually use different topologies
so if gamma is strictly less than one it
doesn't matter what the value is you
will always get the same topology if
gamma is equal to one you get a very
different topology it also e makes a big
difference for decision procedures gamma
is strictly less than one there is an LP
based algorithm to compute the metric
this was also one of the contributions
of Franklin Bruegel and James Worrell
but it's kind of clear that if you
specify so what does it mean to say you
have a decision procedure for the metric
I tell you a certain epsilon and I say
please tell me the metric to within that
epsilon right so you specify an accuracy
well if you know what the discount is
then you can estimate how much how far
you have to go to compute that to that
level of accuracy so it's not difficult
to imagine algorithms to do this in the
case when gamma is equal to one we were
not sure for a long time whether it was
even decidable computable and eventually
von Breugel his student Babita Sharma
and Van Worrell came up with an
algorithm to compute this metric it's it
uses Kenny's result on exist central
theory of the real closed fields in P
space so I think it's a peace base
algorithm
now the whole point of using metrics as
opposed to exact concepts like by
simulation was because one wanted to do
approximate reasoning so underlying this
whole subject was a lot of work on
approximation of labeled Markov
processes and of the metric that
describes these things and that's what
we've been doing for quite a long time
now so one of our early approximation
results was even when you have one of
these big uncountable state spaces
continuum you can still find a sequence
of finite state approximates to any LMP
such that the following things hold that
sequence converges in this kind of
metric to the original LMP so that's
very nice in fact you can say more so
remember that an LMP is described by the
formula as it satisfies you want to know
whether a particular formula holds of an
LMP you can actually prove that any
formula that's satisfied by the LMP will
be satisfied at some stage by one of the
finite approximants and later on Jozy
they are nae and Van Santa knows through
related results they said okay if you're
interested in just this family of
formulas and not generically knowing
what formulas another NP satisfies we
can tell you how far to approximate it
so that he would get definite answers to
the formulas in that restricted class so
that was kind of nice you can actually
orient your approximation process and
skew it towards answering specific
defined class of queries okay so it
converges in the metric to the original
LMP now one thing I didn't talk about at
all in my lecturers is domain structure
it turns out you can actually make the
collection of labeled Markov processes
into a continuous domain so there are
well obviously they're not there are no
compact elements but it's still got a
base of things that you can think of as
finite elements
it's in fact Omega continuous and you
can show that this approximates that we
constructed actually form a directed set
in fact a chain and converge in order as
well okay so the order convergence and
the metric convergence actually coincide
both give you a notion of approximation
of labelled Markov processes and in fact
by solving an appropriate recursive
domain equation you cannot construct a
universal LMP a final Co algebra if you
wish if you wish to use that language
but roughly speaking what it means is
that any LM p can be embedded inside
this universal one yeah does this work
for any metric space but you need
something nice like polish or analytic
you need quite a number of nice things
so the domain Theory thing has analogous
two main theoretical it's got to be loss
and compact something something domains
definitely not yeah definitely not any
old spaces but of course it's in that
category so if I'm building a universal
LM p4 on top of polish spaces and it'll
be any LM p on any polish space would be
embedded in this one or we did it so the
purely metric one was done by Frank and
Ben but the domain one so any one
defined on one of those domains which
will basically loss and compact domains
you can you can embed any any LMP
defined on such a thing inside this
Universal one
so what are these things good for like
what what do I do with a universal thing
like that
sorry show it off on your mantelpiece
but you well so the distance between
processes are actually exactly the
distance that that their images are in
the universal one
yes yes you did you build a yeah an
inductive construction exactly the same
way that one normally solves recursive
domain equations okay so one can also do
all this with MDPs
which is where you have rewards as well
as all the other parameters that one has
in Markov processes and now you can do
some quite interesting things with this
you can give bounds on approximations to
the optimal value functions and all the
papers we wrote on these things tend to
appear in in AI conferences or machine
learning conferences rather than in the
logic conferences but an example of the
kind of thing you can do is the
following so let's say you learn a
certain policy for an MDP on some
example and then you say okay I'm going
to try and transfer what I've learned to
some other MDP not the one on which I
learned it and how good would that be
right so it was optimal for this one how
good would it be for the other one on
which I'm going to use it perhaps you
trained it on a small example and you
want to use it on a big example well
unlikely to be optimal but it turns out
you can bound how far it is from optimal
in terms of the metric between the two
lmps
so it gives you some control on how
things like value functions behave so
this you might think of the is a great
thing unfortunately you can also try to
use metrics to give you clustering
techniques for collapsing bigger mdps
down to much smaller ones unfortunately
computing the MDP is much more expensive
sorry computing the metric is more
expensive than computing the value
function in the first place so this
motivates algorithms to approximate the
computation of the metric and there are
a number of papers some based on instead
of trying to compute everything exactly
in the as we did in the purely
theoretical work but using sampling or
using some kind of asynchronous update
you don't
bring everything all the time or yeah so
there are various approximation
algorithms as you can see these things
also tend to appear in machine learning
conferences so this is where I'm hoping
that all these algorithms people running
around in the parallel program will be
able to help me come up with I'm sure
much better things than what we have
come up with for computing this metric
I said right in the outset that one
didn't want to compute what didn't want
to use pure equations for reasoning and
then that was supposed to motivate the
use of metrics but how do you use a
metric as a reasoning tool in any kind
of logical sense and you know I used to
mumble about this but Gordon plot can
reveal the answer which was to introduce
a quantitative analog of equation of
reasoning so you annotate the equation
symbol with this real number epsilon and
you develop a theory of equational
reasoning so I'm not going to tell you
more because I'm hoping somebody will
ask me to give a talk on it or better
still you can ask Gordon to give a talk
on it when he's here Radu Madara will be
talking about this at the upcoming
uncertainty workshop but this is
something I'm I'm quite excited about I
thought it was a naive idea when I was
first listening to it I was like how
much can you do with that but we were
able to do some things that surprise me
for example write down a small system of
equations that give you the kantorovich
metric simple equations not particularly
nasty ones and small variations will
give you other metrics like the total
variation instead indeed the hausdorff
metric is given by yet another simple
equation old theory written in this form
so so this is I think starting to give
us a real handle on approximate equation
of reasoning this is just equation or
logic and I think there's a whole world
to explore with more met rised forms of
logic whatever that might mean finally
having gone on and on about measure
theory in the end I must say I think
measure theory as it is often done is
very painful there's all this stuff
about oh this is true on everything
except a set of measure zero this is
almost surely true this is almost surely
they're all these almost to me sometimes
accumulate to become never so one of the
things is that why do these why do you
get results like that it's because what
can sometimes really see out of measure
theory is the values of integrals and
when you have things that are you know
undefined on sets of measure zero they
don't affect integrals that you compute
it's precisely what measure zero means
there are things that being changed on a
negligible set
so one should recast the whole subject
in terms of linear transformations on
the space of random variables on
integral functions forget measures work
with the algebra of measurable functions
so we've actually done that we've
written a long ish paper it's just
called approximating Markov processes by
averaging but it in fact it includes
many things many of the things that we
did leading up to the approximation work
was all redone from this do alized point
of view and there's some very appealing
things there for example when Santa Anas
one of the co-authors found how to
express conditional expectation is a
nice in a nice fun toriel fashion so I
think this is this is the this is the
way I'd like to think about probability
the future anyway we've come to the end
of the bootcamp except for Val tannins
guest lecture and I must say I have been
really pleased by the by the number of
obvious opportunities there are to
collaborate and interact across the
disciplines I have seen you know the
obvious connections of course between
androgens work and and the stuff that
poky on defined and between other pairs
as well and even Sampson and I seemed
well we've been friends for a long time
and have many things in common but right
now the only thing I can relate to in
his from his last lecture is
probabilistic collapse so I think I will
stop here before that happens
questions
answers
okay let's say sure well you see them
that's right they do so you see them in
the place where you have to say stuff
like where you prove that this is
equivalent to the traditional view
there's a reach like theorem and then
you have to say that once you get past
that no it's all gone and it's yeah
doesn't mean it's all trivial but at
least that particular annoyance is gone